if you guys had daughters um I know you
said you have a son so I don't care if
it's not a daughter but if you did have
a daughter would you tell your daughters
to be virgins until they're married so
they can avoid toxic men and drama
hell no I don't think you can tell your
children to be virgins they're gonna do
what they want to do right but
regardless of what you tell them is
gonna benefit them later in life so so I
I would say but as as parents you have a
lot of influence so I mean you can't
control them yeah but like like my dad
is someone I listen to a lot so if I
ever have like a business decision and I
can't decide one way or the other I
often go to my dad and I take his advice
a lot so if you were in a position where
you did have maybe not control but a lot
of influences that way you would say no
I would tell my daughter to wait okay
um because there's a big age gap between
me and my brother and I taught him like
the importance and the spiritual aspects
of sex and that allowed him to keep his
virginity to for quite a long time and
he was actually like you know what I'm
glad I waited so if I can have that
influence on my brother then why
wouldn't I tell my daughter to wait and
I'm not just gonna be like wait
because of the social implications of
well what we call you know sleeping
around and all of that I'm going to tell
her about the emotional aspect with it
that you know the physical aspect what
it does to your body if you start having
sex too early too young how men view you
so they have a more holistic kind of
perspective because oftentimes when we
as young people are more informed we can
make better decisions sometimes parents
use abstain or be celibate as a scare
tactic and it's usually because of
pregnancy
that's what I think okay what do you
guys think I think that
like having sex in a relationship is uh
an important step to understand a lot of
things
even like as an individual as a person
if I have a daughter I want her to feel
free to having a hope and conversation
with me of course I will advise to her
to wait until no 18 years old to be more
aware but at the same time I will say to
her be responsible on your choices like
protect sex yeah but
if if for use feels natural I want you
to be yourself and to experience that do
you think that that could possibly leave
your daughter open to predatory men
because when you're 18 you don't have
the life experience to really know the
difference
and so if you're saying like do what
feels natural like the guys that make
things feel natural have studied women
if you have a really good first date
he's practiced men men aren't like
naturally we're very confusing a guy has
to practice to understand us
yeah but at the same time you you
educate your your daughter to be like
independent and smart and like clever
and you like as a parent you you don't
know if you you your work is good and
spot a list I think you as a mom you can
say at least you're trying to give to
your song what do you think is right and
then it's gonna be up to him or up to
her to make the best decision for her
because at the end of the day is an
independent person I can try my best but
I will never gonna control your action
right but I'm not talking about control
I'm talking about influence because I'm
with you I think like kids need to make
their own decisions to some extent
because they can't get to a certain age
and have never made a decision for
themselves right but at the same time
it's like as a parent if you have a good
relationship with your kid you have a
lot of influence yeah of course and I I
just I'm not sure that saying to do it
when it feels natural is great it's
natural in terms that if in that moment
I I don't know probably your first
boyfriend you experience and for you it
feels natural to have that first time
with that person that you really feel
into into deep just enjoy and embrace
that moment that's what I'm saying I'm
not saying yeah
I just if I had like a kid I would just
say be careful because I there's only so
many times you can fall in love yeah and
like and every every time you I I think
every time you get your heart broken you
can't fall in love as deep with the next
person and you only have so much
oxytocin you can give to guys and so if
you really want to feel bonded with your
husband and their wedding on your
wedding night and like when you get
married to him you don't want all these
memories with other guys
like like to me that's that's choose
carefully you mean
um I mean I would say the ideal is to
wait till you're married I think it's
harder in this day and age because I
also don't think men value virginity
like we used they used to because if
you're a top 10 20 guy and you have like
a [ __ ] on speed dial like why would you
not why are you waiting for a virgin
yeah why are you even getting married at
all you know what I mean so it's it's a
different world but I mean I think the
ideal is telling kids to wait till
they're married if they can't if they
want to get married and have kids that's
a really old-fashioned way of looking
it's so realistic I think no I know a
couple people that have done it they're
very happy
they're like they're probably the most
in like I have one friend like she she
waited till she was married she never
did anything like not even you know like
waiting till you know not even other
stuff yeah and she's very in love with
her husband like very in love in a way
like that I don't think I've ever seen
other girls like bond to their husband
the way that like she looks at him
I would get my um kid to like aim for
that so aim for marriage aim for the
idea of you're gonna hold out and like
if you if you hit the clouds then that's
what it is you don't get to where you
need to be I'm also because I understand
that you made a great example with the
predatorial behavior if you're saying
like do as you feel if I'm a guy who's
understood the game and I understand how
to make women feel yeah I can then allow
manipulate the girl into feeling the
type of way and if she's been taught do
as you feel
I could do what I want and then leave
and that will cause her trauma as
opposed to if I've told my child to wait
it out for as long as possible
it's more so okay I don't do this
because I'm trying to weigh out for as
long as possible until I get something
most guys that are trash bags won't stay
the duration and she'll be able to
filter out the men that are not looking
for something real
and possibly get the guy that she
deserves and I'm not saying this is
always the case but it's a good way of
filtering out
um the bad men yeah and I would also add
to that for me the ego thing in my
daughter's side I'd have to out early
it's like listen you need to you need to
clock the game right you've only got so
much time this is the game I don't
expect you to be celibate and all that
but
your time you know be careful about your
time and you need to find the highest
quality man as soon as possible and then
you try and be the greatest version of
yourself with that guy so you want a
Ferrari but you want to be a red to that
guy's Ferrari a lot of girls these days
think that they're going to be like a
competing car like I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be like also a car and then we'll
just be together and it never works in
fact that's the best way I know whether
I want something casual with someone
like
when I've gotten to know them because
I'm just looking I'm just listening for
you to kind of say stuff like that and
it's like yeah we're not we're not going
to go far that's that's how I know
because she she's actually lucky
competing with me she thinks she's gonna
be like match my energy and stuff like
that and I'm like yeah but that's not a
wife so you know what something that I
heard like guys here and like girls say
that like we think about completely
different so they call it like solipsism
where girls we think everything's about
us basically so if you say oh I went to
the gym I'll be like oh I went to the
gym too and we're just saying it to have
something in common but men look at that
as you're competing with me and I and I
never I never thought about this like
that because as a girl that's just how
we talk
[Music]
certain kind of things you know you know
the narrative
in two months she's gonna tell you
everything that's wrong with you
not everyone who like when you've
injured a body part right you can't use
it can we can we just all agree we can't
use an injured body part yeah so what
are we instructed to do not use it yeah
right hold on and then what heal
I'm talking about internal organs I'm
talking about things that no don't don't
know I'm gonna let you land I'm gonna
let you land like muscles you need to
work things need to be strengthened but
there's a resting period that's really
important and I think if we can apply
that like emotionally we might not look
at the word healing or working on self
as such an alien concept we have to look
at the body sometimes and the spirit and
the mind right anyway I'm coming with
all that holistic stuff so but also
healing right the definition of healing
is like so so something's been damaged
it heals and then it goes back to its
somewhere near its original
functionality it's not really healing if
you go on a healing Journey now you're
less capable of loving you less capable
of born you're more judgmental you know
it just sounds you're more into yourself
you start saying stuff like um I mean
honestly I think it's more honest to
just say your damage from every
heartbreak but then that's why like it's
not that you're not going to heal from
it like this you might you might improve
but like there's no going back once
you've been yeah no no no you don't
you're not you're not gonna okay you're
not gonna be better out of as a virgin
at 18 or you know I'm somebody oh maybe
earlier I don't know 16. and
you're a virgin then you've had three
boyfriends and they all broke up maybe
one or two was toxic you're not gonna be
better after you're worse
you're you're a worse product but you're
you should put yourself on sale
even have like completely damaged their
cartilage and they decided to change
their lifestyle change their diet get
alternative therapy and their cartilage
well it's okay that's like regenerated
I'll give you an example so that's like
a car right that maybe you repainted it
a potential to regenerate itself it's
not not really but that's why this
sounds no okay you gotta let me talk if
we're gonna like not really like you
can't you can't you can't go through
three toxic relationships and come out
better you're worse put yourself on sale
and like that's honest
and like so when guys here when guys
hear healing like it's like a car okay
if it's got issues under the hood you
might be able to fix it but it still has
a history of issues under the hood and
you can repaint it and make it look
better but it's still a worse product
and it gets put on sale so after a
certain point you've had so many
relationships you put yourself on sets
it's okay then and like honestly you
should have like it it's a sign of ego
if you say I can't put myself on sale as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible